all right let's move to this
really we've just been leading up to
this i think it's the most important
story
snopes has a fact check on the claim
that joe biden farted while meeting with
the duchess of cornwall
and the verdict right now from snopes
they did look into this and they say the
verdict is unproven so this is what they
say an anonymous source told the daily
mail the u.s president biden farted
during his meeting with the duchess of
cornwall despite headlines claiming that
camilla parker-bowles can't stop talking
about it duchess has offered no public
comments on the matter it should also be
noted that this rumor started amid a
series of unfounded claims regarding
presidential farts
no other evidence has emerged about
these alleged emissions no other sources
have acknowledged this possible piece of
presidential flatulence and while a
number of news outlets have repeated the
claim that the duchess of cornwall
hasn't stopped talking about it she has
not made any public comments about biden
breaking wind so snope says we can't
confirm or debunk whether biden truly
farted while meeting with the duchess of
cornwall we can say that the evidence
for this uh fart is scarce that it's
based entirely on a single quote from an
anonymous source and that it's made its
way around the internet on the heels of
several other false fart rumors now uh
they have declared these other rumors
you know they've declared them rumors
and they've said that they're false but
we don't know that either
so there's a lot we don't know and we've
got to be honest about the situation i
think i think when you're staring at a
situation and uh and there's there's
there's really no evidence one way or
another you've got to be honest about it
did joe biden release exhaust from the
tailpipe right in front of a member of
the royal family
did he do this only a week after dumping
a load in his pants in front of the pope
um
these are questions we have no answer to
all we can do is we can look at patterns
all right
and there does seem to be
an undeniable pattern
wherein joe biden is being accused of of
of
gastrological activity shall we say
often in front of notable international
figures
his colon seems to be especially
aggressive
in europe in particular
is there a connection there is this even
part of some kind of national defense
strategy i don't know is joe biden
being sent over to these other world
powers to deploy something of kind of a
skunk strategy sort of emitting an odor
as as a way to warn off
predators on the national or the
international stage
i don't know
i can't say nobody can say
i just wish that our media would start
asking these kinds of questions
um
if i were in the media i would
but you know they they they're they
would ask joe biden about uh
about what what flavor ice cream he
likes
but they won't ask about the flatulence
potentially caused by that ice cream all
i could say for sure this is one thing
we know for sure let's just hope that
joe biden
and eric swalwell are never in the same
room together
all kinds of epa regulations will be
violated in a situation like that so i
think we could say that at least if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and share it with all your
friends